what's it called cheese stirring away
interesting I didn't know that
so Caroline what uh tell me about your
past my life I lived in Santa Ana for a
few years then we moved up in the world
and Fountain Valley nice and we I grew I
went to private school Liberty Christian
school wouldn't know that huh and I got
molested in fifth grade there and for
the
the time till 8th grade there I had a
miserable life because the person that
molested me his children still went to
the school and so did I my parents
weren't gonna back down and take me out
of school they went to the police he got
his own lie detector test he got away
with it anyways the gist of it it says
about fifteen years later they they
caught him gives molesting his son his
babysitter's his daughter but I had to
go through all those years of everyone
in the school thinking I lied and made
it up because they were the rich family
of school I was terrible and they did
everything for everybody so from 5th
grade till 8th grade I lived in hell
because I didn't get invited to certain
things because parents thought I made it
up all right
the boys later on I bet they figured
that out on the side on them
Douglas Whitney yeah he's the one who
molested me yeah that's when my life
changed I was a happy child I got
perfect grades I still got perfect
grades but something happened to me
after that something changed in me and I
never was the same because number one
because they didn't believe me and I
felt like well that's it the police or
four you know and some change in me and
that's what I became promiscuous I
didn't have sex love at 17
everything else promiscuous probably
happened about 17 but I was curious
about that
sure sure but after I had sex the first
time then it was on it crackin
and I met this guy who was who is he was
27 I was 17 it was my birthday coming up
so I met him and I started doing cocaine
with him as he was 27 he was one of the
owners of Billabong okay he had he had
it going on I was 17 living in this big
beach house in Huntington Beach but I
still wasn't the same I changed from
that nice little girl that I was I
changed and I started doing cocaine with
him snorting it once in a while he would
he would get with his buddies once a
while and snort that I would all of his
friends were pro surfers he was a pro
surfer I always left for uh sir I died
world he is a goofy foot he won the
Katyn amateur he was hot you know you
know front of Billabong Here I am 17
so after snorting coke I am I did I did
a little bit of speed he got hooked on
speed they lost everything through a
time because he had a lot of money to
[__] off but he eventually lost he sold
out the billabong started a company
called Saul we lost that
and that was the demise of our
relationship was crystal meth because I
really loved him and he left me I was
engaged to him
I thought we'd be together forever
anyways after that he ended up hooking
up with a porn star type of gal and I
didn't eat for a month and I never
really was the same after that either
relationship-wise I was with him for
five years I felt like [__] it you know
I'm just gonna [__] guys and I got I
started drinking more and then I I dated
Charlie Sheen
I never knew that was to tell you my
friend Gigi introduced me I never
remember that she was
Paige for me I never knew I was
oppressed no would you okay when I say
prostitute I didn't know I was supposed
to be when I wasn't one I had never sold
sex for money ever so after I found out
she was getting money for me a lot like
she got to go to the ATM every time he
saw me go go to town you know
then he would offer me money he never
treated me like a prostitute always
treated me like like a precious gem
mm-hmm
I don't believe any of the stories I
hear in the media at all because I spend
enough time with him that I know the
hitting and stuff if he walks away from
the girls and so many ways long story
short GG introduces him to me so then he
starts giving me money a lot of money
but never hears her sex she would he
would say I want to let's he'd go in his
office and write me a check to he'd be
like what charity is this work I don't
know and I'd get a check for five or
seven eight thousand dollars right
things like that and he was really good
to me he taught me a lot I went to Costa
Rica
I went to Costa Rica with him right
after my brother passed away my brother
was a fighter pilot and I drank so much
I blacked out pretty much the whole trip
this Tom had just died and that's with
Charlie and of course we had piles of
cocaine we got off a delivery car who
was Tom throw your brother past me
me and Charlie got out of the [__]
supposed to Rica it was like we had so
much cooking it was funny
piles imagine
Charlie kind of broke my heart a little
bit but I had to expect that would
happen anyways after during that time I
tried to stop drinking several times but
I couldn't do it on my own I kept going
back to it and so I joined a a that
didn't really help then
one girl introduced me okay
I had Jeff as a boyfriend and I used to
date this guy William Shockley he was on
a show dr. Quinn Medicine Woman
we never did drugs together a little bit
of coke we smoked a lot of weed we drank
a lot my drinking escalated during that
time a year and a half with him living
with him my my alcoholism got worse so
after that I left him and I met my
baby's dad Darren who was wonderful to
me and tried to help me all that he
could and then I broke up with him and
he decided we were still friends he took
me out for my birthday and that's when I
got pregnant Kayla we weren't together
anymore but we still love each other for
friends and so after about 10 my ties we
went back to Ramirez Canyon and there
was Kalyn Lee my daughter who's 13 now
and doing really good I have a
relationship with her - to this day now
that's correct
it's getting better but
I truly believe that when people say
drugs Escalade you want to start smoking
to leave and you think you're gonna just
keep smoking away that's [__] you
know there's none for most people it
escalates there are some people that can
do it and some people yes sir I'd say
there's about 25 percent of the people
that can just smoke weed and have a
couple drinks and it's cool
but I think maybe maybe 60%
did you see it happening early on or did
it just kind of take over it I saw
myself being depressed and sad not
knowing who to talk to or why it was
happening I lost my brother that was
because they didn't find his body this
is the wreck this was Virgil this is
routine exercises off to Kittyhawk in 96
oh and mom had coffee that morning she
was driving and said I heard there was a
prowler accident he flew the Prowler
it's a 65 million dollar plane and his
mom said there was an accident didn't
think anything of it we go the whole day
they have to reach you either Western
Union or at your door he never came to
our door it's 11 o'clock at night so we
think we're home free I go in my excited
my wing with a house of sudden boom boom
boom I ran my mom had to hear that
lieutenant Thomas Robert France you know
you know the US Navy is presumed dead or
lost at sea and my dad wasn't even home
he was in Vegas he never used to ever
leave I think God spared him that ton at
that time because that that that
situation with the chaplain my mom has
clear doors I'll never forget it to this
day
taunts me seeing the officer in the chat
through the glass and having to meet my
mom and he wouldn't open the door
finally she could pose or something said
okay stop crying stop screaming we're
opening the door and that's what had
happened and then that crushed me
just that the seeing that the chaplain
and officer plus obviously the news and
then hearing that they didn't find my
brother's body and not being eligible to
marry him it's really hard for us and so
I found myself even that night in a
blackout just drunk you know changing
homes were you at this time I was 26 I
was 40 right now 14 15 years ago so 34 I
mean yes I'm sorry 25
at my supposed to be at the prime my
life I didn't have any babies you know I
was free I had a good job I always had
good jobs I work for Ocean Pacific
Division of Bailey corporation as a
merchandise assistant I know my
aesthetician is license and they did
very well in Calabasas I had me a means
to make money here we were still doing
drugs at this time those who you got off
this is these are years before oh this
is all before I was doing heroin when I
was being an esthetician at Rosie
skincare in Calabasas I was
so everything kind of kicked in after
your brother passed away yeah alcohol
but the heroin started in I lived in
Calabasas at Malibu candy apartments and
I met this chick Belinda and I never I
couldn't stand heroin addicts you
couldn't even be around me if you did it
heroin heroin was the bad word my dad
always told me my whole life he said
never get on here we're just those
heroin addicts they can never get off
God anyways how did you first get on
heroin well anyways Belinda usage I
would be hanging out with her and she'd
be smoking it on boy like a ham right
here and I'd be wondering like what the
[__] I thought junkies slammed you know
I thought they [__] just jacked
her arm up and well she she was alert
she was cleaning her house and doing all
kinds of [__] while she was smoking this
dope so I didn't I didn't do it then I
said I asked her questions about it okay
then she offered me some and this girl
Julie justice was there and she said
don't you dare give Caroline that you're
dealing with the devil if you dare give
Caroline that [__] I'm going to beat
your ass whoop zuly left and I tried it
and I went home to my place in Calabasas
i sat on my couch I swear it was like
sin I didn't feel them on the station I
didn't feel the breakups I didn't feel
my brother's death I didn't feel [__] I
just felt like everything
then on the following day I start buying
dope for Belinda and her husband I
didn't know quantity they used me as a
tool to buy their dough okay well I bet
I found a dealer in Topanga candy now
it's all good every day I Drive to pick
a can ever hundred Oz was a dope I was
running a household I had babe daughter
going to PTA meetings running games just
doing keeping up with everything
no one knew not even Mike my mate said
didn't it outside the logic Rob laundry
and that was attached from our house I
took the the what he called I took the
ball ad the ad was a smarter I had the
socket so nobody who would ever want to
go in that room you know what I mean I
made it so unattractive so that was my
room I put the bulb in when I went in
anyways I got on that my dealer got
busted in Topanga and somebody told me
go to skid row okay so here I am in a
freaking BMW wagon pulling up to San
Julian and I met this lady named scooter
in a wheelchair and she was my first
dealer and that's when I got my first
heroin and I fool around the block and I
do bags I had money and I didn't think
my life was being ruined because I was
smoking it I was going back to Malibu
mmm I did all this while my daughter was
at school unfortunately I don't I'm not
proud of that I know it's
but I did it but I don't think it takes
away from the fact that I love my
daughter and I love her as much I want
to say one thing
drug addicts can still love their
children as much as they did when that
baby was born I believe that but but for
some reason we we do we do but it
doesn't take the love away it doesn't
mean you don't love your children people
but not me
anyways so I came down here and then a
scooter got busted so I started making
my way and then one day I wanted to get
really high and I was ceiling cracked
and I decided I'll get a hotel okay I'll
call Jeff Kayla was with her dad for two
weeks
so there was no reason for me to be home
Jeff and me had already been having
problems he was going to Kabul a lot so
I stay in a hotel well anyways about a
month later Kayla's dad when Jeff found
out I was doing this [__] tailless he
called Kayla's dad my daughter's dad and
said I think Kayla needs to come with
you and Caroline needs to go to rehab
that was the plan well then she went
with her dad
and I stayed down here I didn't go to
rehab and I stayed over and over in
hotels and over and over and I need to
run out of money for a long time but
when I did I had gotten offers for
prostitution before and I'd be like well
I shut the [__] up
but one day dawned on me well I could be
a prostitute I swear it never even
entered my mind to be a prostitute okay
and all of a sudden I was like I could
be a prostitute
give me some condoms and I went out
there I think the first card picked me
up was a guy in a black Tahoe and he
ended up to be a cop later on about a
year later the cop car was following me
I'm like what the [__] I didn't do
anything all of a sudden I'm like okay
whatever he pulls over opens the window
and I look at him and he said your
message box is full you gotta clear your
messages and I had looked into my go
you're a [__] cop you bastard you
could help me out on cases yes that was
the first trip
misuk Hawk became still to this day lead
a well he's a sheriff he's a captain Iza
okay but I'm not he's not from this area
maybe not these aren't the sheriff's
okay anyway some and then I went from
there and I'm jealous of crazy tricks
tricks or days
what else you want to hear some work
right yeah that's a great story not one
when I when I tell me tell us where you
were when I first found you you're
you're with us behind a fish market
well Chicago's a squadron and he has a
shack made of a cardboard and plywood
and just scraps yeah actually where I
lived it was like a it was like a big
plywood bookcase but it was thick okay
and I had the bottom shelf it's like
this much room I had to sleep okay kids
you know Michelle had the middle of
Chicago at the top that's where we live
and that's where you found it right I
remember the first time I walked in i
was there several times but the first
time I walk in here's this short little
black guy I'd like to talk fast with
four beautiful women four beautiful
women all either passed out or half
naked yeah he's having sex with all of
you guys not you I made him work on it
and he decided that he was gonna try to
pull game on me and say am I wearing a
condom well that ended our sex
relation also made me have to pay to
live there but I didn't mind because I
don't want to be [__] it especially
summer of course here yeah so anyways
yeah we were living in that Shack
then he got we got we got busted the
LAPD the Red Shirts never we went
through so much [__] over there one day
the red shirt said get over there where
the hand come here go [__] you and I
start running yeah I go out ran I got
away from the red shirts because they
don't have guns they just have cuffs so
somebody doesn't have a gun you better
believe I'm gonna outrun you know if I
can't so yeah
you met me there and then from then on I
got I got a little better but then I
came back and here we are and you got
pregnant again
right around my birthday I was living at
the Mayfair Hotel I was on methadone for
the beginning of that then I got back on
dough and I tried methadone I tried my
hardest and then my baby's dad was
always [__] with me and [__] every
girl on the block and lying to me about
it we heard stuff I was pregnant and I
got back on Joe yes I did that's like
the worst thing like I've done in my
life I don't have a lot of skeletons in
my closet but I did that to a baby
I did that to a baby and to this day
it's like I can't forget myself in fact
I'm getting my tubes tied this wee
I can't myself
but luckily he doesn't have any problem
so we had him evaluated he walked on his
tippy-toes he's done with that now he
walks flat on his feet he took two steps
he seems to not have a hyperactivity
problem many ways I was on methadone at
the end of my pregnancy too but I did
use his name's Charlie this is so cute
he's with your mom my mom but since she
has cancer
chance he might not let her adopt him if
I get my [__] together I can yeah but
it's a little bit harder now because
it's been a little bit of some time I am
but that's really the worst
baby I will get it down I don't its I
don't know why I did it I don't know why
I couldn't stop but something that [__]
noms me and it makes me feel okay it
also gives me an appetite
I don't know but I don't know why I did
it but I know I think if I had another
baby which I'm not I know I couldn't do
that again okay did I hope he does not
promise in the future was learning and
all that stuff
he seems okay right now I my mom she's a
stern lady and she's she tells me the
truth you know she thinks that I got
lucky because of the fact that I smoked
heroin
if I were shooting it you would have
been getting it like right so much more
but the fact that I smoked it doesn't
make it any better in life but pregnant
it's like 90 percent better than
shooting it so hopefully he doesn't
[Music]
where do you see yourself in five or ten
years
I want to be better than I would I want
somebody in my life share my life with
but no one's gonna really want somebody
that's doing this you know or I could
afford it you know I care about blue
probably because he's like a father
bigger than he is 72 we became really
close to my dad died we were close
before but really really close there's a
loanshark that that you stay with
sometimes
maybe I don't love it but you gotta just
think of security but now he constants
deep and he made it so how old like 10%
and usually he doesn't even ask
I usually just kick him down a little
bit of money here and there but he's not
a pimp just for the record he doesn't
like pimps he he likes old-school pimps
but these pimps nowadays he knows I'm a
renegade a renegade means I don't have a
pimp and I never have had a pip I've
never had it no [__] my money
ever I've never had a pimp
I've had pimps trying to irrelevant
means steal me but then lose Pippy as a
loan shark yes he is but I hate it when
people say that because I'm not gonna do
it was my money for free no way Caroline
what would you say to your kids one day
if they saw this and years down the road
I would say you already know what you
know but now that you're seeing this and
I hope they're God you'd never choose
this road
they obey you listen to Grandma auntie
and daddy then I hope you guys go to
college I hope you guys have a good life
and I hope you find people in your life
love you and I hope that because you
don't have me in your life right now
it'll choose the wrong person because
that's what happens to kids that don't
have their parents around but I know
that you see a shrink
Kayla and you know that she tries to
deal with you about losing me but you
always have be you know you always
happen you could always call me you
always talk to me but
we'll continue to see the therapist no
you choose a good man I know that I
always love you no matter what I do I've
been I'm trying to get her back she
knows this isn't just me leaving her she
knows that I've tried to get her back
and I've tried a lot of things but they
basically since I'm a heroin addict I
don't have any [__] what's the word
for it I don't have any credit
credibility even though I'm not a
bullshitter a lot a thief
my can be at my mom's house without her
there okay she's got she's in pocket you
know I've never taken a goddamn ting for
a drop I've never seen this to my kids
I've never you know the only thing I've
ever done is I gave a guy my phone to
get a bag of heroin and then I bought
the phone back I've never sold anything
and I don't want you to ever be stealers
don't ever be a thief because if you're
a thief in my book you're you're you're
stupid and you will go to jail and you
don't need to steal you got grandma you
can even ask me for money you know that
Kayla I'll send you the money and
but I want to say that Charlie is I'm
sorry if I did anything to you that harm
to if I if I did any anything I didn't
mean it and I and I tried but I didn't
try hard enough
I hope you'll forgive me I hope I hope
both of you guys will free advice and I
hope we could have remember your first
11 years of life spending all the time
with me I hope you'll remember the
bedtime but daddy always tries to make
you think of the bad times you don't
expect Isis how much I love you how I
free you a smoothie to somebody's house
if you didn't like what they were making
you or bring you a salad cuz you should
want to eat macaroni and cheese all
those things I watched yours ever all
the clothes and all the love and all the
snuggles and then all that stuff oh I
hope you remember that you know
about me I'll get over this stuff I'll
get through it I'll get through it it's
just taking me a little bit longer this
is our destruct to get off up if you
ever have to try and try don't do this
please please don't try it smoking it
doesn't matter it doesn't bad Caroline
thank you so much